mais je pense qu'il faut dire aux gens
si on bouge pas qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer dans les dents linate dans les
prochaines années à venir on voit qu'il
ya des choses qui se passent dans des
pays et des chaudes et des condés des
conditions climatiques des phénomènes
climatiques qu'on voyait pas avant et on
a l'impression que ça se dégrade de plus
en plus vives louis qu'est ce qui va se
passer dans les quatre cinq ans à venir
bon je vais turlock moi non mais ce que
je sais c'est que le secrétaire général
des nations unies s'est pas c'est pas le
patron john peace un scellé secrétaire
général de la coi il dit qu'on va vers
une catastrophe climatique culminante il
faut savoir que le climat qu'on a eu
pendant vingt mille ans il est parti à
jamais il ne reviendra pas le climat
qu'on a eues il faut le savoir mais voir
qu'on apprenne à s'entraider à lui d'une
façon différente a peut-être avoir une
beaucoup plus de bienveillance pour la
vie autour de nous est-ce qu'on n'est
pas capable de regarder ce qui est
vivant autour de lui d'une autre façon
alors moi évidemment votre documentaire
je les trouvais absolument magistral je
trouve à la fois poétique et lyrique
c'est pour moi une déclaration d'amour à
la planète mais pour autant sur le fond
le côté de la surpopulation puisqu'on
montrent bien que dès 1960 et en et 2
milliards et là on est à 7,5 milliards
même un peu plus comment on fait en fait
on trie l'ins et la politique de
l'enfant unique
comment on va faire par exemple parce
que vraiment vous parler de l'avion dont
l'avion ok on ya une sorte de tourisme
de masse où tout le monde a pu aller où
peut aller à l'autre bout du monde avant
la pandémie est une terreur mais alors
comment on fait on trie alors on va dire
- alors les jours ici ils peuvent
prendre l'avion parce qu'on va augmenter
les tarifs
et puis les gens pauvres non ils n'ont
plus le droit voyez ce que je veux dire
en fait c'est un fait mais j'ai pas les
personnes liées à la production on peut
tous aujourd'hui prendre l'avion
seulement si c'est essentiel pas le
point avant poser un week-end à
marrakech
en tout on a tous fait ça donc c'est
vrai que l'on pourra plus le faire
aujourd'hui
je pense que j'ai pas la solution n'est
pas la solution mais on est bien
évidemment il faudrait que l'espèce de
gouvernement mondial à cause de ce qu'on
s'entende
si la france tout seul décarboniser côté
on fait pas notre commerce
notre balance commerciale va s'écrouler
ça l'homme politique il a été il est élu
pourquoi pour préserver le pouvoir
d'achat et les emplois donc décarbonés
le pays c'est prendre des risques mais
vous lui faut être courageux dire la
vérité je vais vous dire ce qui va
changer quand on sera aujourd'hui quand
il ya la marche pour le climat à paris
on est 50 milles dans la rue le jour on
sera 3 4 millions manifester comme
l'arrivée comme pour l'arrivée la coupe
du monde du show le changeront les
politiques ce n'est que le miroir si on
a envie de changer tous ensemble on
changera c'est vous en parler tous les
jours
si vous êtes dans votre vie c'est
quelque chose d'important c'est ça qu'il
faut savoir c'est faux oui j'ai
confiance d'une émission l'émission vous
êtes tendance de vous moquer un petit
peu de tout mais ça on peut pas se
moquer de la vie des enfants et mes
petits-enfants peut pas le faire on n'a
pas le droit de le faire mais je suis
d'accord avec vous mais alors pourquoi
vous engagez pas en politique parce que
je ne serais ce que je faisais le giron
politique c'est bien plus que ça c'est
un vrai débat politique que j'amène ont
fait réfléchir des français je pense que
ce film là qu'on affecte mon équipe
comme tous les écolos hulot n'a pas été
capable de faire des folies terry les
bienvenus mais moi je suis pas plus
capable que 1000 chacun son boulot et je
pense que les hommes politiques
j'imagine le savez il ose qui raconte
quand il a fait 2000 réunion quand il
était à 2010 qui prenait des décisions y
recevait des appels de partout
c'est extrêmement compliqué c'est un
autre métier moi je fais pas ce métier
là